[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Channel
Awesome's orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world
the pop culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather ruse and I ran away and this
is your news for Monday November 6 first
up we wanted to talk about a couple
trailers like at release this week
including a first up the disaster
artists newest trailer if you thought
that your feelings were gonna be all
belts and stuff from that last trailer
uh who picked wait this newest trailer
shows you will have all the fields for
Tommy oh my gosh I can't freakin wait
for this movie it's gonna be incredible
the hype is so real I'm sorry Co looks
amazing yeah that laughs down incredibly
oh my goodness just I I can't freakin
wait for this film it's gonna be so good
and it's gonna be in theaters on
December 1st which is so soon I feel
like we've been talking about it for a
while and it's it's coming I've been
talking about it for it's too long
remember it's never too long to talk
about this movie another trailer that we
got this week was for downsizing which
is a new movie starring Matt Damon and
the premise of this is kind of unique in
this world humans are able to downsize
or shrink themselves to five inches tall
and they kind of hint at the fact that
this is done for conservation reasons so
maybe because of resources or the human
footprint and print in the world but
Matt Damon and his wife who's played by
Kristen Wiig decide that they are going
to make the plunge and downsize except
Matt Damon's wife chickens out and
doesn't actually end up downsizing with
him so then it seems like he goes on
this adventure he starts his new life
over goes sees the world a little bit
maybe runs into some new people has some
new hope for Humanity it seems
interesting something that's unique and
different which is always something that
we're looking for iMovies something
that's new and it's coming out in
December 22nd so it seems like a movie
that you might be a
to take your family to during Christmas
pike very true um this week we also got
a couple of announcements about new TV
shows that may or may not be happening
one of the first things we heard about
is the new warriors Marvel TV show
doesn't have a home anymore it's kind of
been kicked off of freeform they didn't
really have too much space for it on the
network so now it's looking for a new
home a new network to to call its home
and what complicates this a little bit
is since Marvel is owned by Disney they
can only really look at channels that
are owned by Disney so there was news
that maybe it'll be moved to the
streaming service but they're really
trying to push for a 2018 release date
since they've already been slated to
begin production in January of 2018
we've already got our Squirrel Girl cast
they're already set to go Squirrel Girl
is going to be Mila vine true mallanna's
our Milano vine troupe who looks fun
looks good
we'll just gotta hope that we're gonna
see Squirrel Girl sometime soon right in
the new warriors I mean eventually we'll
see here but like sooner rather than
later is better yeah right right
especially if they're ready to go right
if everything's all set hope it's gonna
get a new home soon yeah
another thing that's in the works is a
Twilight Zone reboot
Jordan peels production company monkey's
paw came out and said that they're
looking to reboot the series it's going
to be a show run and screen written by
Marco Ramirez of daredevil and the
defenders so it looks like it's already
starting Productions and with all the
anthologies that are coming out we got
to go
not our tip of the hat to the og at
Twilight Zone I'll definitely check it
out it sounds incredible except that
it's streaming on CBS all access yeah I
mean I guess they're just really pushing
it they want you to only get the service
get that streaming another streaming
service that might be producing a new
show is Amazon is in talks right now
with Lord of the Rings to do a new Lord
of the Rings television show which seems
like a strange choice the movies are so
iconic it seems like we really don't
need this it's
not something that the world necessarily
needs we've already kind of milked the
story you had the Hobbit trilogy and
that already added some things that we
hadn't seen in the original Lord of the
Rings trilogy to it so it doesn't seem
like there's much new content to be
shared of course there's always things
that they skip from the movie and write
but I don't I don't see a need for this
right now
again it's still in talks so we have no
idea if it's actually going to happen
and what's going to come of this but
they're talking I don't see too if the
movies had the budget that they have how
a streaming service is going to make any
sort of quality content anywhere near
that needed I don't see it happening I
don't know I would love to be pleasantly
surprised
great Game of Thrones type of thing but
I doubt it right you know damn Thurman
says HBO that budgets a little bit
different than Amazon Prime streaming I
don't know maybe we just really need
more talking in the woods yeah maybe
maybe we also have some really exciting
casting news this week first we'll talk
about the rise of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles show it's a 2d animated
show that's coming out on Nickelodeon
I'm surprised that they're getting rid
of their 3d animated go her instead for
this but I'm excited about the cast
which is as follows Omar Miller will be
playing Raphael Josh Brener is going to
be Donatello Brandon Michael Smith is
going to be Michelangelo and a banished
Schwartz is going to be Leonardo he's
the words I'm just kidding he's
generally oh no such animal yes right
anyway we like it works attract that's
right he's amazing
Kat Graham is going to be playing April
O'Neill which I'm very excited for and
Eric Bauza bows up it's going to be
playing Splinter I'm very excited about
this calf lineup it looks really cool
all the voice actors I'm really excited
for the only thing I'm not as excited
for is the character descriptions at
Nickelodeon release kind of makes it
sound like Raphael and Leonardo are like
switching characters weird
their character descriptions are
opposite Leonardo is simply the coolest
brother with a rebel heart and Raphael
is the oldest the biggest
and the leader of the crew so like why
oh yeah I mean it's been established for
a very long time that this is their
personalities I know sometimes they got
a priest of new life is your your ties
but like why this why well can't we make
another choice mmm maybe nice I don't
know we'll see I'll definitely watch it
though that'll be out on Nickelodeon uh
the other casting news we have a very
excite
for The Lion King live action cast the
biggest the bestest is the greatest the
queen bee herself beyonce is going to be
playing Nala oh my goodness
so excited she's gonna be playing
opposite of dummy clover as Simba as
well as how perfect is that casting
speaking of perfect casting yes it was
fuzzy John Oliver gonna be awesome
oh it seems like I'm not sure if we need
this but now no I need this Oh more
people they keep adding I need it even
more including keegan-michael key is
going to be playing
kumari and Eric Andre is as easy Eric
Andre come on
hilarious ah it's going to be so great
so I will say I'm a lot more excited for
the Lion King remake now wasn't before
well and we've known some of these
casting choices for quite a bit right
but it was there was something special
about seeing that poster that they kind
of released on Twitter that had everyone
listed out with their pictures that just
got me so excited about it that made me
see the whole cast the whole picture
which was a great play I think just yeah
everyone listed out there is broad widow
excited it was it was very Broadway got
me very excited 2019 cannot come soon
enough now I'm so excite it's gonna be
great just I know the animation we're
probably going to like it some like
moves back dates I'm less dream because
Jungle Book and their animation like
it's gonna be it's gonna be a long time
but also they need the time so alright
so take fine make it good make it just
that I learn so much about
now it's secondhand yeah another a fun
thing that's happening this week is
Pokemon in Japan is getting its 1,000th
episode of the television series they're
gonna have a huge celebration and it
just seems like good for them you know
makes me feel a little bit that's so
many episodes and thousand episodes
every one mm okay Wow Wow although
there's actually some debate right now
as to whether or not it is actually
they're 1,000 episodes the Pokemon
company is saying that yes it's the
thousandth episode but they're also
including all of the TV movie specials
as well as the infamous porygon epilepsy
episode it's what they're including in
there so some people are saying is it
really or a thousand but hey if it was
on TV
it aired make sense to me on their last
accounts and anyways then not counting
those in a couple episodes for then
it'll be 1,000 that way right right
doesn't matter um another Pokemon thing
happening is in 2017 in Japan you can
get a little app an extension for your
Alexa or Google home that lets you talk
to Pikachu look seems very unnecessary
right they're very very super fun
it's obviously not gonna inform you of
anything I'm gonna say Alexa give me the
weather it's just gonna do a little like
hey yeah okay sure this is the first
TomTom to r2d2 though so alright there
you go I'm fine with it it kind of
reminds me a little bit of the n64 game
Hey You Pikachu you guys
yeah that was a lot of fun yeah that and
pokemons not so many good 64 Pokemon
games oh yes good stuff
oh man well I guess that's gonna be it
from us if we miss anything this week
let us know in the comments down below
if you have an opinion on anything that
happened this week also let us know in
the comments down below and you can also
follow us on social media
oh there where can they find you you can
find me on Twitter at Heather Ruth's
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch.tv
slash Heather roofs and as usual you can
find me on facebook at i anna-wade or
everywhere else as awesome Ayana and we
will be catching you next week guys so
in the meantime beam us up
[Applause]
you